Seabiscuit
It was the height of the depression and America
was in desperate need of a hero.
They found it in the most unlikely of places
. . . a battler who looked about as beat up
as the nation itself.
For a racehorse, he didn’t have much going
for him.
His legs were too short, his neck was too
thick and he had a swaying foreleg that jutted
out wildly.
Worst of all, he had a mind of his own.
When he felt like running he’d run, when
he didn’t, he wouldn’t.
It’s hard to believe that this horse, having
lost his first 17 starts, would become a legend
– the greatest racehorse in history.
In this episode of Biographics we reveal the
amazing story of Seabiscuit – the horse
that brought a nation together.
* * *
Pedigree
Seabiscuit was born (or more accurately ‘foaled’)
on May 23rd, 1933 in Lexington, Kentucky.
He was the son of a nasty-tempered rogue named
Hard Tack, and a gentle mare named Swing On.
Seabiscuit’s father had great speed, no
doubt owing to his own pedigree.
His father, Man o’ War, was considered by
most experts at the time to have been the
greatest racehorse ever produced…
although his grandson would certainly go on
to challenge that claim.
The problem with Hard Tack was that he was
uncontrollable...
Even hall of fame trainer ‘Sunny’ Jim
Fitzsimmons couldn’t tame him.
Seabiscuit’s mother was the complete opposite
of Hard Tack.
She was a calm, gentle horse with thick knees
and short legs.
Swing On wasn’t very fast though, so she
never raced...
The colt that she sired didn’t look very
promising.
His legs were stubby, his knees were thick
and he looked sort of ‘funny’ when he
ran.
Even Seabiscuit’s color was against him.
He was a solid muddy bay with no distinguishing
white stripe or star on his face.
These horses were all owned by Ogden Mills,
Secretary of the U.S. Treasury and his sister,
Mrs H.C, Phibbs.
Their racing stable was one of the finest
in America, with no expense being spared in
the care and training of the horses.
However, Mrs Phibbs insisted that only horses
that would bring honor to the stable be kept.
The only reason that Hard Tack and Swing On
were still around was that they both had strong
pedigrees.
It was hoped that their offspring would have
amazing speed…
During his first year, Seabiscuit, along with
his mother, was put into a 50-acre pasture
with nine other thoroughbred mares and their
newborn foals.
In every group of colts there are usually
two that stand out – one is the hero, the
better looking, more graceful, and faster
one; the other is the outcast, an awkward,
looking runty little fellow who looked as
if he slipped in when no one was watching.
In this group the hero was Granville, and
the outcast was Seabiscuit.
But, something in Seabiscuit stood out to
keen observers.
Several times a day the colts would race up
and down the paddock with Seabiscuit always
at the rear.
Yet, the gangly colt was never discouraged.
The farther he was left behind, the harder
he drove himself – and the longer the race,
the nearer he came to catching up.
With his big head and short spindly legs,
Seabiscuit spent more energy than the other
colts in running.
As a result, he had a larger appetite than
the other colts.
He developed stronger and tougher leg muscles,
and by late fall he was no longer running
at the back of the pack…
Emerging as a yearling on January 1st, 1934,
Seabiscuit looked more like a ragged range
pony than a thoroughbred.
He had failed to shed his winter coat and
his legs and back were a few inches shorter
than average.
In fact, he was such an ‘ugly duckling’
that when Mrs Phibbs came in April to inspect
her horses, Seabiscuit was hidden away in
an outlying barn.
By now, though, Seabiscuit had found his running
legs.
He was challenging Granville for the lead...
He may not have had the physical attributes
of the other horses, but he was full of stamina
and determination.
By mid-summer the rivals were racing neck
and neck.
It was then that Seabiscuit developed a habit
that would be a trademark for the rest of
his life – whenever they were vying for
the lead, he would snort at Granville, as
if attempting to bully him and throw him off
pace.
Training
In June, 1934 Granville and Seabiscuit were
shipped to ‘Sunny’ Jim Fitzsimmons, recognized
as the finest trainer in the country.
Fitzsimmons had developed a hatred for Seabiscuit’s
father, Hard Tack, after years of being unable
to break him of his vicious habits.
He had also given up on Swing On, finding
her too slow and lazy.
This did not bode well for Seabiscuit, who
Fitzsimmons looked upon as a curse from the
very beginning...
He put the majority of his energies into training
Granville, while forcing Seabiscuit to conform.
Seabiscuit, meanwhile, was determined not
to comply - he simply refused to go fast!
Finally, an exasperated Fitzsimmons gave his
jockey a wooden stake and told him to ‘hit
Seabiscuit just as many times as you can in
a quarter mile.’
They ran him against Faust, the fastest sprinter
among the group.
In trying to escape the severe beating, Seabiscuit
exploded around the track, leaving Faust far
in his wake.
He ran the quarter mile in 22 seconds and
2/5ths.
If you didn’t know this is a pretty incredible
time…
It amazed Fitzsimmons, but it also confirmed
in his mind that Seabiscuit would only show
his potential under severe punishment.
When, on January 1st 1935, the horses under
Fitzsimmons became two-year-olds, Seabiscuit
was tossed aside.
He was put to work as a hack racer.
On January 19th he was entered into a short
race, losing by four and a half lengths...
During 1935, he ran a total of 35 races, losing
the first seventeen.
Not a great start…
It was only when his jockey stopped beating
him and let him run his own race that he showed
real promise.
He won five races, setting three track records
in the process.
Still, Fitzsimmons was desperate to get rid
of him, convinced that Seabiscuit was an inconsistent
no hoper.
On August 3rd 1936, Fitzsimmons entered Seabiscuit
in the $6000 Claiming Stakes at Saratoga.
Fortunately for him, this just happened to
be one of those days when Seabiscuit decided
to turn it on – he won by six full lengths.
Up in the stands an old time cowboy and veteran
trainer, Tom Smith, saw heart and courage
in Seabiscuit.
He decided that he had to have him.
A week later Seabiscuit was purchased by Charles
Howard for $8000 and handed over to Tom Smith
for training.
The horse finally had a trainer who both respected
him and saw his limitless potential.
Seabiscuit was subjected to an intense conditioning
campaign.
The horse that no one had wanted was pampered
and groomed with a focus on foot care to recover
from the gruelling schedule he had been forced
to endure under Fitzsimmons.
As a result of the care and attention that
was lavished upon him, Seabiscuit began performing
more consistently on the practice track.
He became gentler and seemed to develop a
competitive spirit.
He also developed a huge appetite, eating
anything that was put before him.
To keep his weight down, grooms were instructed
to muzzle him at night to prevent him from
eating his straw bedding.
A combination of kindness, patience and the
skilful training of Tom Smith managed to transform
Seabiscuit’s courage and intelligence into
raw, unbridled speed.
All that was needed now was to match Seabiscuit
with the right jockey...
Racing
Smith found him in the form of Jack ‘Red’
Pollard, a feisty 27-year-old Canadian, who’d
been roaming around the west riding and boxing
for over a decade.
His love for thoroughbreds was as deep as
Tom Smith’s...
Yet, although he was one of the better jockeys
on the bush circuit, he’d won only three
stake races in his life.
When Red first entered Seabiscuit’s stall,
the horse was busy munching on straw.
Seabiscuit looked up, gave a snort and then
ambled over to Pollard and rubbed his muzzle
against Red’s shoulder.
And with that, one of history’s great partnerships
was born.
Satisfied that he was ready, Howard entered
Seabiscuit into a series of races in Detroit.
In two races, the Detroit Governor’s Handicap
and the Scarsdale Handicap, he came home first,
netting $12,900 in prize money for his owner.
Over the next two months the winnings accrued
to a remarkable $40,000.
A delighted Howard gave him a two-month vacation...\
In November, 1936, Seabiscuit was sent by
rail to California to compete in his last
two races as a three-year-old.
The first was the Bay Bridge Handicap.
Despite starting badly, Red and Seabiscuit
soon found their stride and they won by five
lengths.
In their last race of the year, the World’s
Fair Handicap, they led from the start, cruising
to an easy victory.
By the beginning of 1937, Seabiscuit was beginning
to develop a reputation as an up and coming
champion.
The focus in the early part of the year was
March’s Santa Anita Cup - the biggest race
on the West Coast.
Seabiscuit started the year well, winning
a warm up race at Santa Anita in January.
Then, in the San Antonio Handicap, he was
bumped at the start and pushed wide, finishing
a disappointing fifth.
Now it was time for the big one – the $125,000
Santa Anita Cup.
Coming down the home straight, Seabiscuit
was a half-length ahead of Rosemont, the horse
which had won the week before at San Antonio.
But Red Pollard, who was blind in his right
eye, didn’t know that Rosemont was closing
in and failed to urge Seabiscuit into the
next gear...
Rosemont won by a nose.
This disappointment though, was followed up
by three easy wins, establishing Seabiscuit’s
reputation on the West Coast as the breakout
thoroughbred of the year.
By this time Charles Howard was making some
pretty great money off of his investment.
But he wanted more.
He was determined that Seabiscuit be recognized
as the greatest race horse in the entire United
States.
That meant breaking into the far more prestigious
East Coast circuit.
So, between June 26th and August 7th, he entered
Seabiscuit into five east coast races, and
won every one of them.
He finished 1937 with a record of 11 wins
out of 15 races and was the biggest money
earner in the country.
He was also now the most famous horse in America,
with the press having a field day with his
underdog story.
The nation’s most prestigious equine award,
however, did not go to Seabiscuit that year.
The winner of the American Horse of the Year
Award was the darling of the East Coast set,
War Admiral, who had just won the coveted
Triple Crown.
Rivalry with War Admiral
Interestingly, War Admiral and Seabiscuit
were actually blood relatives.
They were the son and grandson of one of the
greatest thoroughbreds in history, Man o’
War.
Seabiscuit’s father, Hard Tack, was War
Admiral’s brother.
In 1937, War Admiral won every race he started,
including the Triple Crown.
This prestigious honor is bestowed upon thoroughbreds
that win three major races in succession:
The Kentucky Derby, Preakness Stakes and Belmont
Stakes.
But War Admiral’s victory at Belmont…
it was bitter sweet.
An injury prevented him from racing again
for several months.
War Admiral was a natural competitor.
The lively activity of race day seemed to
fill him with nervous excitement.
He was so competitive it was difficult for
handlers to hold him back when the saddling
bell rang.
His temperament was fiery and skittish - just
like his brother Hard Tack.
But this personality usually worked to his
advantage.
He never willingly walked into the gate and
once the starters got him in he would act
up causing delays and false starts…
At the beginning of 1938, War Admiral was
the best horse in the east and Seabiscuit
was the best horse in the west.
Race fans were anxious for the two champions
to meet.
But Charles Howard knew that despite the public’s
fascination with his unlikely star, if Seabiscuit
were to be taken seriously as a challenger
to War Admiral, he would have to establish
his own reputation in the east.
Howard was a master promoter and he capitalized
on the established racing rivalry between
the east coast and the west coast.
He was determined to prove that a horse coming
out of California could be the equal of anything
that ran in the east.
He began issuing public challenges to Sam
Riddle, the owner of War Admiral.
Riddle ignored him, considering it demeaning
for his champion thoroughbred to meet a western
horse...
After months of incessant media chiding, though,
well, he finally agreed.
Fastest Horse in the USA
The question of who was the fastest horse
in the United States would be decided by way
of a race to be held at Pimlico Racetrack
in Baltimore, Maryland.
This would take place on November 1st, 1938.The
distance was one and three sixteenth miles.
Riddle insisted, however, that the race begin
with a no gate, or walk-up start, to avoid
War Admiral’s temperamental behaviour in
the gate.
Howard agreed to start the race with a starting
bell, but he also had a condition; the track
had to be ‘fast’ or dry.
Seabiscuit did not run well in the mud.
If the track was too wet because of rain,
the race would be called off.
Then things started to go wrong in the Seabiscuit
camp.
Red Pollard fractured his leg while working
with another horse and was unable to race.
Pollard’s good friend and fellow top jockey
George ‘The Iceman’ Woolf would ride Seabiscuit.
Up until that time, every match race in history
had been won by the horse that was in the
lead from the start.
Throughout all of his races in 1937, War Admiral
had never let another horse in front of him.
Yet, Seabiscuit was a ‘come from behind’
winner.
War Admiral’s trainer George Conway and
jockey Charley Kurtsinger were confident that
their horse was faster than Seabiscuit.
So, they concentrated on building War Admiral’s
stamina to endure the mile-long distance.
Meanwhile, Tom Smith was concentrating on
the start of the race.
He put together a homemade bell that started
like the starting bell at Pimlico.
When he rang the bell, Woolf cracked the whip
on Seabiscuit’s backside.
This conditioned Seabsicuit to run at top
speed immediately.
The race of the century was a worldwide sensation.
The race track was so crowded that ten thousand
people crowded outside the gates, sitting
in trees, and standing on cars roof tops to
try to see the race.
Across the United States 40 million people
tuned in to their radios.
Many of them had never before cared about
horse racing but now were eager to hear history
being made.
Most of them were rooting for Seabiscuit.
Charley Kurtsinger, on War Admiral, wore black
and yellow silks and rode the rail, while
George Woolf, with red and white silks, sitting
astride Seabiscuit, took the outside.
War Admiral prepared for the race the way
he always did, rearing up and tormenting his
handlers.
Meanwhile Seabiscuit calmly headed for the
post.
The flag was raised and the horses lined up.
But just as the starter was about to ring
the bell, Woolf pulled Seabiscuit back.
It was a tactic to make War Admiral nervous.
When they lined up a second time, Kurtsigner
pulled his horse back.
On the third try, both horses lined up at
exactly the same moment.
The starter bell rang and they were off.
The two thoroughbreds pounded down the track
neck and neck.
It was commonly believed that War Admiral
would take the early lead.
So, the crowd were astonished when Woolf cracked
the whip and Seabiscuit edged in front.
Around the first turn Seabiscuit was still
ahead.
Woolf veered left and took the rail from Kurtsinger.
Then he slowed Seabiscuit right down in front
of War Admiral in order to conserve energy.
Kurtsinger now either had to slow down himself
or pass Woolf.
War Admiral drew closer but Seabiscuit was
still ahead by a length and a half.
Going into the backstretch, the distance widened
to two lengths.
Then Kurtsinger cracked the whip and in just
a few strides War Admiral was even with Seabiscuit.
The crowd were going wild.
The horses charged down the straight, neck
and neck.
Then War Admiral took the lead, but only for
a moment as Seabiscuit sped up.
He was in front again...
Turning into the stretch it was anybody’s
race.
They rounded the far turn and were headed
for home.
They were coupled shoulder to shoulder, head
to head, eye to eye…
Around the turn as they headed for home, Woolf
cracked the whip, asking Seabiscuit for everything
he had.
He loosened the reins and his horse answered.
Dropping his chin, his ears pinned back he
raced toward the finish line.
The crowd were astounded to see Seabiscuit
break away by one, two, three lengths.
In the end it was no contest.
Seabiscuit was the winner by four lengths;
leaving War Admiral in his dust.
As Seabiscuit slowed to a gallop, thousands
of fans burst through the infield chasing
their underdog hero.
In the winner’s circle Seabiscuit was donned
with a blanket of yellow flowers.
War Admiral’s barn met their defeated champion,
and slipped away almost unnoticed...
Seabiscuit was now, not only the national
racing champion, but the fastest and most
famous horse in the world.
He easily won horse of the year in 1938.
However, the joy for Seabiscuit was short
lived.
In his very next race he ruptured a ligament
in his leg.
He spent most of 1939 healing at the Howard
ranch in California.
The comeback for both Seabiscuit and jockey
Red Pollard, still recovering from his own
leg injury, was to be the 1940 Santa Anita
Handicap.
During the race Seabiscuit got caught in a
pocket, which Red tried desperately to get
out of.
Finally finding his gap, he yelled, ‘Now,
pops!’
Seabiscuit broke through, took the lead and
never looked back...
Retirement
Following the Santa Anita victory, Seabiscuit
retired with a record of 33 victories from
89 races.
He had earned Charles Howard $438,000, an
American record at that time.
Seabiscuit died suddenly of a heart attack
on May 17th, 1947.
Three years later, Charles Howard’s horse
Noor won the 1950 Santa Anita Handicap.
When a reporter suggested that perhaps he’d
found another Seabiscuit, he answered . . .
‘Sir, there will never be another Seabiscuit.’